ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung im
Seminar über politische Philosophie
heutiges Thema ist das Thema politische
Gerechtigkeit der Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit ist sehr zentral im
politischen Weiler unser Zusammenleben
auf eine Weise bestimmt die das
Zusammenleben
angenehm verträglich stabile macht und
weil der Begriff der Gerechtigkeit auch
das Verhältnis zwischen Individuum und
kollektiv Gemeinschaft Gesellschaft auf
eine sehr verständliche Weise herstellen
lässt gerecht sind Individuen
Bericht können aber auch soziale
Strukturen sein und das Grundproblem der
politischen Philosophie besteht ja darin
wie sich das Verhältnis gestaltet
zwischen den einzelnen Personen den
Individuen ihren Eigenschaften ihren
Vermögen und dem Kollektiv dem Person
Verbund oder auch noch stärkeren
Systemen wie Staaten oder
Bürgerschaften Polis hat man das in der
Antike genannt wie ist dieses Verhältnis
genau zu verstehen und für dieses
Verständnis hilft uns der Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit
wir werden diese Thematik der
Gerechtigkeit der politischen
Gerechtigkeit anhand von John ralls
diskutieren einem sehr bedeutenden
amerikanischen Philosophen der eine
Theorie der Gerechtigkeit verfasst hat
die sich sehr gut auf den Bereich des
politischen anwenden lässt ich gebe
jetzt erstmal eine allgemeine Einführung
in das Thema Gerechtigkeit wichtig ist
dass wir überhaupt alle politischen
Begriffe auch alle moralischen Begriffe
überhaupt alle philosophischen Begriffe
zunächst eine Abgrenzung vornehmen von
dem Gegenteil also hier interessiert
auch immer der Begriff der
Ungerechtigkeit wie verhalten sich
Gerechtigkeit und Ungerechtigkeit
zueinander eine weitere Frage ist die
genaue Beziehung zwischen Gerechtigkeit
und Recht
Rechte sind in der politischen
Philosophie auch zentral vor allem
natürlich die Grundrechte die uns hier
in Deutschland durch das Grundgesetz
garantiert werden wie zum Beispiel freie
meinungsäuß tun und so weiter und so
fort das sind alles Grundrechte die
machen auch den Liberalen Zug unsere
Gesellschaft aus also hier wie verhält
sich Gerechtigkeit zurecht
Gerechtigkeit kann als juristischer
Begriff in Rechtsordnungen verstanden
werden er kann aber auch als
philosophische Begriff verstanden werden
und das ist ein Unterschied
Gerechtigkeit wird nämlich in
philosophischer Hinsicht häufig auch als
eine Charaktereigenschaft gefasst und in
juristischer Hinsicht wird Gerechtigkeit
häufig an oder recht häufig gefasst als
Eigenschaft eines Systems eines Vertrags
eines Verhältnisses zwischen
verschiedenen Parteien der
philosophische betrifft erlaubt es auch
nur auf eine Charaktereigenschaft oder
auf Charaktereigenschaften von
Individuen angewendet zu werden es gibt
seine weitere wichtige Unterscheidung
die Unterscheidung zwischen Naturrecht
und positivem recht
das besagt diese Unterscheidung diese
Unterscheidung betrifft die Frage nach
begeltung und nach der Entstehung und
der Begründung von recht Naturrecht
bedeutet uns kommt das Recht von Natur
aus zu damit muss jetzt nicht unsere
biologische Natur gemeint sein es ist
möglich aber auch sowas wie ein Wesen
also das Wesen des Menschen zum Beispiel
das Wesen ist die Natur von uns das
heißt von Geburt an ohne soziale
Umstände so wie wir eben immer schon
sind das positive Recht hingegen
bedeutet das recht künstlich gesetzt ist
das bedeutet auch positiv von lateinisch
ohne setzen Leben stellt also sozial
gesetztes Recht was uns nicht von Natur
auszukommen natürlich haben beide Formen
von rechts oder bei der Auffassung von
Recht vor und nachteile Naturrecht
erlaubtes recht sehr stabil zu begründen
ohne Ausnahmen
zu
postulieren
positives Recht hingegen ist ein recht
was vielleicht stärkeren Einwänden
ausgesetzt sein könnte was die absolute
geldung anbelangt auf der anderen Seite
natürlich
ist es immer problematisch sowas wie ein
Wesen anzusetzen
das wirkt häufig wie eine bloße
Voraussetzung die noch genauer begründet
werden muss und hier hat es das positive
Recht wiederum leichter wenn es um die
begründungslogik geht weil positives
recht häufig einen Rechtssystem
enthalten ist aus einem Rechtssystem
folgt und somit viel kognitiven
nachvollziehbarer ist
Gerechtigkeit ist eine Tugend in der
Philosophie häufig die auch als
Personifikation der Justitia dargestellt
wird man sieht hier die Augen sind
verbunden das ist die Neutralität
Unparteilichkeit diese Waage hier gibt
symbolisiert die
Urteilsfindung die möglichst ausgewogen
erfolgt und seine Allegorie und dieses
Schwert hier ist natürlich eine Art von
macht wie auch immer man die macht sich
jetzt vorstellen mag ob man damit die
Exekutive meinte ja häufig von dir
judikativ Unterschieden ist das muss man
jetzt noch offen lassen
politische Gerechtigkeit bedeutet man
muss fragen was macht unser
handelngerecht aber auch noch darüber
hinaus was macht Gesellschaftsstrukturen
oder gesellschaftlichen was macht unser
Zusammenleben gerecht welche
intersubjektiven Strukturen fördern oder
beeinträchtigen Gerechtigkeit diese
Frage müssen wir uns stellen und
natürlich auch wie sich Ungerechtigkeit
Gerechtigkeit zu Ungleichheit und
Gleichheit Verhalten ist Gerechtigkeit
dasselbe wie Gleichheit das scheint
zunächst mal nahezulegen ist aber nicht
der Fall es ist viel komplexer müssen
also immer auch auf den Begriff der
Ungleichheit fokussieren
eine weitere Frage die man sich noch
stellen kann ist die
wie sich Neid und Gerechtigkeit
zueinander zu halten ist Neid eine
gerechtfertigte Haltung gegenüber
ungerechten Zuständen oder Kanal selbst
auch eine ungerechte Einstellung sein
das ist natürlich auch eine ganz
spannende Frage ich hatte schon gesagt
in der Philosophie wird Gerechtigkeit
häufig als Tugend als
Charaktereigenschaft aufgefasst
Tugend und Gerechtigkeit ist ein
normativer Begriff normativ bedeutet man
macht hier Aussagen über den Wert einer
Eigenschaft zum Beispiel eine
Charaktereigenschaft ist eine gute
Eigenschaften man soll das haben
Ungerechtigkeit ist auch ein normativer
Begriff man soll das nicht haben man
soll nicht ungerecht sein es lässt sich
aber auch als politisches Ideal
verstehen als ein Zustand der vielleicht
nie wirklich realisiert werden kann aber
zudem man hin Streben soll
man kann sich auch ferner fragen wie
sich Gerechtigkeit und Rechtfertigung
das zueinander verhalten wir hatten
anhand der Justiz ja Allegorie gesehen
dass sie eine Waage hat in der sie einen
Urteil aus mittelt und auch rechtfertigt
also Gründe angibt wird das Urteil und
sie diese Gründe gegeneinander abwägt
und das scheint nahezulegen das
Gerechtigkeit immer auch mit
Rechtfertigung etwas zu tun haben muss
Gerechtigkeit muss begründet werden muss
gerechtfertigt werden können andernfalls
droht sie zu Ungerechtigkeit zu werden
Gerechtigkeit ist eine Tugend eine
erstrebenswerte Charaktereigenschaft
haben wir schon gesehen sie wird häufig
im Kontext von anderen sogenannten
Kardinal Tugenden diskutiert schon in
der Antike weitere kardinaltungen sind
Mäßigung aber auch Tapferkeit und
Weisheit das sind alles Formen von aus
mittelungen von
extremen Zuständen die hier in der
Tugend eine gesunde Mitte nach aristotel
ist befunden haben wir haben hier wieder
gesehen dass die Tugenden häufig auch
von dem Individuum auf Kollektiv
übertragen werden wir hatten gesehen ich
mache oben rechts ein Link rein zu
historischen Übersicht bei Platon und
seiner Konzeption des idealen Staates
dass er den philosophenkönigin auch eine
Tugend zuspricht nämlich die der
Weisheit und er spricht dem näher stand
den Bäuerinnen und Bauern den
Handwerkerinnen Handwerkern die Tugend
der Tapferkeit nicht zu sondern die der
mäßige und Besonnenheit und dem
Widerstand also dem Polizistinnen den
Soldaten den spricht er die Tugend der
Tapferkeit zu also man sieht hier wieder
man kann das Individuum immer auch auf
das Kollektiv beziehen hinsichtlich
seine Eigenschaften Gerechtigkeit kann
eine individuelle Charaktereigenschaft
sein aber auch eine politische
Strukturen und die soll es heute gehen
Gerechtigkeit ist ein relativ und
situative Begriff Gerechtigkeit betrifft
immer die Frage zwischen verschiedenen
Gruppierungen
deren Verhältnis betrachtet wird in
bestimmten Kontexten in einer bestimmten
Situation kann etwas gerecht sein oder
ungerecht sein in einer anderen
Situation nicht es kommt immer auf die
Umstände an das ist also der der Kontext
der Gerechtigkeit
dem Gerechtigkeitsbegriff liegt der
Begriff der Gleichheit zugrunde auch
wenn nicht automatisch dasjenige gerecht
ist was gleich ist das werden wir gleich
noch sehen
wir können uns auch den Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit über den Begriff der
Fairness ernähren das hat John rolls
getan
recht können nicht nur Personen oder
Handlungen sein sondern auch soziale
Strukturen und Institutionen wenn sie
uns zum Beispiel die im Grundgesetz
verwirkten Grundrechte wie
Meinungsfreiheit
Versammlungsfreiheit Eigentum
Unversehrtheit nicht garantieren
es gibt jetzt verschiedene Formen
politischer Gerechtigkeit zum Beispiel
Bildungsgerechtigkeit dass wir alle
denselben Zugang des Recht auf Bildung
haben zu Bildungssystem dass wir davon
nicht ausgeschlossen werden
Chancengleichheit dass wir nicht von
Geburt an gewisse Chancen gar nicht
erhalten natürlich ist das immer ein
Ideal de facto ist es nie der Fall dass
wir genau die gleichen Chancen haben
Generationengerechtigkeit betrifft eben
unser Verhältnis zu
älteren jüngeren Generation aber auch
noch zu kommenden Generationen die wir
vielleicht noch gar nicht kennenlernen
können ein Beispiel ist hier etwa die
Endlagerung von Atommüll der für
künftige Generation zum Problem werden
kann das ist keine Form von
Gerechtigkeit wenn wir unsere Probleme
in die Zukunft einfach Auslagen globale
Gerechtigkeit ist natürlich auch ein
wichtiges Stichwort globale
Gerechtigkeit betrifft jetzt die gesamte
Welt und nicht nur Regionen auf der Welt
ein Beispiel für globale Gerechtigkeit
ist etwa die Klimagerechtigkeit weil ja
auch
Klimawandel nicht nur bestimmte Regionen
betrifft sondern die gesamte Welt und
sich häufig dort negativ auswirkt wo die
klimaschädicken gar nicht erzeugt wurden
also da gibt es natürlich auch eine Form
von Ungerechtigkeit jetzt kommen wir oft
schon rolls Theorie der Gerechtigkeit
als Fairness zu sprechen er hat ein Buch
geschrieben a serial of Justice eine
Theorie der Gerechtigkeit das ist eine
ganz bedeutendes Werk und er hat sich
auch sonst mit Gerechtigkeit als
Fairness befasst was ist jetzt seine
These er sagt folgendes jedermann soll
gleiches Recht auf das umfangreichste
System gleicher Grundfreiheiten haben
das mit dem gleichen System für alle
anderen verträglich ist und er sagt und
das ist jetzt besonders wichtig soziale
und wirtschaftliche Ungleichheiten
gestalten das vernünftigerweise zu
erwarten ist dass sie zu jedermanns
Vorteil dienen und sie mit Positionen
Ämtern verbunden sind die jedem
offenstehen er geht also immer schon von
Ungleichheiten aus und anders als der
Kommunismus ist sein Ziel nicht diese
Ungleichheiten völlig zu nivellieren
aufzulösen da ist er realistisch genug
dass das nicht geht im Gegensatz ein
Liberalismus bedingt gewissheitsmaßen
auch Ungleichheiten allerdings sind
diese Ungleichheit nicht zu vergrößern
wie im Sinne einer Schere zwischen arm
und reich sondern
die bevorzugten die Begünstigten sind
zu binden an die weniger begünstigten
und ihr Fortkommen wir werden das gleich
noch sehen das ist nämlich dann sein
sogenanntes differenzprinzip das ist ein
sehr wichtiges Begriff den man mit rolls
häufig Verbindung bringt das sagt
geht man von den Institutionen aus wie
sie von der gleichen Freiheit für alle
und der fairen Chancengleichheit
gefordert werden so sind die besseren
Aussichten der begünstigten das ist also
diese Ungleichheit es gibt begünstigte
dass diese Aufsicht eine begünstigten
genau dann gerecht sind wenn sie zur
Verbesserung der Aussichten der am
wenigsten begünstigten Mitglieder der
Gesellschaft beitragen die intuitive
Gedanke ist der dass die
Gesellschaftsordnung nur dann günstigere
Aussichten für bevorzugte einrichten und
sichern darf wenn das den weniger
begünstigten zum Vorteil gereicht hier
wird sozusagen der Vorteil der
begünstigten rückgebunden an den Vorteil
der wenige begünstigten das heißt die
werden nie alleine gelassen es kann
nicht zu dieser viel kritisierten
Scheren zwischen Arm und Reich kommen
zumindest nach diese Theorie weil es
sich eine Rückbindung gibt an diese
Differenz der Ungleichheit also
zusammengefasst rolls negiert nicht
Gleichheit das will die Gleichheit nicht
sagen herstellen
in letzter Hinsicht sind er will
Ungleichheiten aufeinander beziehen und
zumindest abhängig machen da ist er dann
doch ziemlich realistisch er sagt das
noch in einem anderen Zitat soziale und
wirtschaftliche Ungleichheiten also zum
Beispiel die Herkunft der soziale Rang
das
Einkommen oder die das Vermögen diese
immer schon gegebenen Ungleichheit
müssen so geregelt werden die sollen
nicht einfach nur hingenommen werden
sondern in diesem geregelt werden dass
es den am wenigsten begünstigsten die
besten möglichsten Aussichten bringen an
denen muss man sich orientieren wenn es
um Ungleichheiten geht Ungleichheiten
gibt es aber immer so realistisch ist
und mal schon ja das war ein kurzer
Überblick zum Thema politische
Gerechtigkeit ich bedanke mich vielmals
für die Aufmerksamkeit bis zur nächsten
Sendung